so right over here like i've done in
previous videos we have a diagram of a
mass and we really should conceptualize
it as a point mass although it doesn't
look like a point it looks like a like a
circle but imagine a point mass here and
it's tethered to
uh something it's kind of it's tied to a
massless string a theoretical massless
string right over here or functionally
massless string and it's kind of nailed
down and let's say it's on a
frictionless surface and let's say it
has some velocity and right here we have
the magnitude of its velocity in the
direction that is perpendicular to
the the the wire that is that is holding
it or i guess you say perpendicular to
this the radial the radial direction now
based on that we've had a definition for
angular momentum the magnitude of
angular momentum is going to be equal to
the mass times this velocity
times the radius and you could also view
that and this is kind of always kind of
tying the connections between you know
translational notions and rotational
notions we can see that angular momentum
could be the same thing as well the mass
times this velocity you could do that as
the translational momentum rho in the
magnitude of translational momentum in
this direction times r so once again we
took the translational idea multiplied
it by r and we're getting the rotational
idea the angular momentum versus just
the translational one and we could also
think about it in terms of angular
velocity and this comes straight out of
the idea that this v
is going to be equal to omega r so you
do that substitution you get this right
over here
now in previous videos we said okay look
based on this and based on the idea that
if torque is held constant then this
does not change you you can you can
describe or you could predict the type
of behavior explain the behavior that
you might see in a figure it's figure
skating competition where if someone
pulls their arms in while they're
spinning and they're not you know
applying any more torque to spin if they
pull their arms in well this thing is
going to be constant because there's no
torque being applied well their mass
isn't going to change
so
they'll just spin faster and you do the
opposite the opposite would be happening
but you might have been left a little
bit unsatisfied when we first talked
about it because i just told you that i
said hey look if torque is if if there's
no net torque then angular momentum is
constant and then you have this thing
happening but let's let's dig a little
bit deeper and look at the map of it so
you feel good that that is actually the
case so let's go back let's go to the
definition of torque
and so the magnitude of torque i'll
focus on magnitudes in this video
the magnitude of torque is going to be
equal to it's going to be equal to
the magnitude of the force that is in
this perpendicular direction
times r
times r now what is this this force well
this is just going to be equal to
the mass force f equals ma so it's going
to be mass
times the acceleration in this direction
which we could view as
which we could view as the change
in
in this velocity
over time and we're talking about
magnitude so i guess you could say the
the magnitude of the velocity in in that
direction
and then of course we have times r
times r
now if we multiply both sides of this
times delta t
we get
we get and actually we do tau in a
different color you torque in green we
get torque times delta t
torque times delta t
is equal to
is equal to
mass
times
delta v
delta v in that perpendicular direction
times r
well what's this thing going to be
what's this
well that's just change in angular
momentum so this is just going to be
change in angular
momentum and there's a complete analogy
to what you you might remember from kind
of the translational world in the
translational world you have this notate
notion if you take your force and you
multiply it times how long you're
applying the force actually let me do
this in a different color
so you multiply it by how long
you are applying the force so this con
this quantity we often call is impulse
impulse that's going to be equal to your
change in translational momentum
your change in translational momentum
and if you have no force then you're not
going to have any change in momentum or
you could have your conservation of
momentum or it's not going to change
it's just going to be conserved and then
you can do all sorts of neat you know
predicting where a billiard ball might
go or or whatever else we have the same
analogy here
the the the analog for force in the
rotational world is torque it's
obviously it's force times
kind of radial
times that radial distance but
if you take torque times how long you're
applying that torque that's going to be
your change in angular momentum
so if you're not applying any torque if
your torque is zero
if your torque is equal to zero well
that means that your delta l is zero
your angular momentum is not changing or
you could say your angular momentum is
is constant so if you don't apply any
torque
like once this figure skater's already
spinning and he or she she's not pushing
to get more to spin so she's not
applying or he's not applying more
torque well then their angular momentum
is going to be constant but they can
change they can change their rate of
spinning by changing r by changing how
far in or out r is or how far not the
masses are obviously i said in the last
video a figure skater is a much more
complicated system than a a point mass
tethered to you know
tethered to a
tethered to a rope you could view a
figure skater as kind of being modeled
by a bunch of point masses but hopefully
this gives you the idea